[Music]
i want to talk uh briefly about
something that's pretty cool something
we just introduced at the team coco
website uh with help from our partner at
t and you just got to check this thing
out because
i hate everything and i was impressed by
this it's a tablet app that lets you
watch our show on two screens
simultaneously your tv
and your tablet and that way you can
interact with friends and other fans
while you watch the show and there's all
kinds of stuff there like behind the
scenes photos trivia to check out and uh
you can use the tablet app with any
recent episode of the conan show now
here's the really amazing thing about
this app is that when you turn it on
it hears the audio from our program on
your tv or dvr and then it immediately
knows where you are in the show and it
syncs you up
instantly and then starts telling you
cool stuff about behind the scenes
spontaneous while you're watching the
show yeah now how much does this
incredible app cost
that's the best part
nine thousand dollars
wow yeah worth every penny no how much
does it cost it costs absolutely nothing
it's free you can get this amazing free
tablet app sponsored by our exclusive
partner at t at teamcoco.com
[Applause]